all right colin is with us in Missouri
hey Colin welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show
hey there Dave how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up well I'm a
17-year old high school seaman right now
and I wanted to do aviation my entire
life I'm looking at a state school
that'll be about 150,000 dollars for
four years and then after that and the
airline's after about five years I'll be
making about $100,000 per year I'm gonna
try and apply for as many scholarships
as many anything as I can but I was just
wondering if you think that that's a
good idea to go to to pursue a career in
aviation so why is it a hundred and why
is it thirty seven thousand dollars a
year for a state school exactly a
tuition regular housing food everything
like the tuitions that's what's that
what's how much is the tuition my belief
tuition by itself is about ten thousand
per year that sounds right okay and so
you need 27 thousand dollars worth of
food in the housing
well no it's because the aviation
program specifically for plane rental
and everything it's an extra 75 grand
per year all right excuse me for the
four years total so it's double yeah
basically okay and how are you paying
for this I would be taking on student
loan my parents no no I would not do
that yeah
alrighty I'm gonna do what you're gonna
do as I can tell by the way you said
yeah alrighty but no I would not do that
I'm gonna find another way to do this or
I'm not gonna do it
I mean I'll join the military if you
want to go into aviation that's an
excellent way to do it and they'll pay
for all of this and a hundred and fifty
thousand bucks in your pocket for
serving your country plus they're gonna
pay you while you're there and yeah you
can definitely come out of there and go
into the airlines without any question
they do it all the time lots of
captain's on the Front's of the Jets
have been first served in the cockpit of
a military
jet of some kind so yeah no no I'm not
going 150 grand in debt I'm gonna keep
shopping I'm gonna look for scholarships
I'm gonna consider stuff like the
military I'm gonna consider another way
to skin this cat but I'm not gonna tell
you do this because here's what can
happen you get almost out and something
happens and you don't get the hundred
thousand dollar your job but you still
have all the debt this is what happens
52% of people that start college finish
it
that means 48% of those that took out
student loans with the promise of a big
income later are screwed because they
don't finish the degree well that's not
gonna happen to me Dave
I know right that's what they all said
or they wouldn't have started it so dude
no this is a bad idea not going in debt
for it if you can figure out a way to
cash flow it working get your parents
involved get scholarships go the
military something like that I don't
mind you living this dream but there's
not a chance I'm gonna sign you up for a
nightmare not on my watch you do what
you want to do you're going to anyway